BUT, FIRST, THE LIAR, THE WIMP,
AND THE WARDROBE.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
YOU GET THE SENSE THAT WHEN
DIRECTOR COMEY ENTERED THE FBI
BUILDING, IT BECAME LIKE THE
WARDROBE IN THAT FAMOUS C.S.
LEWIS BOOK.
HIS OPEN FANTASY LAND WITH RULES
THAT DIDN’T APPLY TO MERE
MORTALS.
WELL, TODAY, THE SUPERCILIOUS,
PIOUS, SANCTIMONIOUS FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR JIM COMEY WAS ROASTED.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND HE
WAS IN CLEAR VIOLATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE GUIDELINES
AND HIS SWORN DUTY IN HANDLING
INFORMATION RELATED TO HIS
DEALINGS WITH THE PRESIDENT AND
THE DOSSIER.
NOW COMEY’S CONDUCT WAS AN
AFFRONT TO THE STANDARDS
EXPECTED OF ALL DOJ EMPLOYEES
AND A STAIN ON THE LONG, PROUD
HISTORY OF THE FBI.
BUT TONIGHT HERE’S WHAT YOU NEED
TO UNDERSTAND.
COMEY ALONG WITH CLAPPER,
BRENNAN, STRAUBING, AND McCABE,
PERHAPS OTHERS, PLANTED
THEMSELVES AS TRUMP-RESISTING
SUPERHERO, SELF-APPOINTED
SAVIORS OF TRUTH, JUSTICE, AND
THE AMERICAN WAY.
WELL, DEEP STATE ACTORS, THEY
LOOKED THE OTHER WAY AS COMEY
ABUSED HIS POSITION.
ALL THE PRIVILEGES AND POWER OF
THE FBI IN A PLANNED EFFORT TO
DESTROY THE MAN HE HAD UTTER
DISDAIN FOR.
DONALD TRUMP.
NOW, COMEY COMES FROM THE
NOW, COMEY COMES FROM THE RARIFI
RARIFIED UPPER CRUST OF ELITE
WASHINGTON LAWYERS.
TO THEM, TRUMP FROM THE OUTSET
WAS AN UNCOUTH REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED REALITY STAR, THE
ANTITHESIS OF WHAT MANY OF THESE
SELF-APPOINTED ELITES WANTED IN
THEIR PRESIDENT.
NOW FOLKS LIKE COMEY,
THEMSELVES, HAVE COASTED FOR
YEARS ON THEIR PEDIGREE AND
PUFFERY.
THEY DON’T LIKE DISRUPTER,
BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE TRUMP,
THEY’RE GOING TO PULL BACK THE
CURTAIN ON THE STATUS QUO, THE
OLD GUARD.
THE ESTABLISHMENT.
THEY DON’T LIKE THAT ONE BIT.
THE IG REPORT TELLS US THAT
COMEY METICULOUSLY PLANNED
EXACTLY HOW HE WOULD INFORM
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP OF THE
SALACIOUS DETAILS CONTAINED IN
THAT STEELE DOSSIER.
HE CO-LEWDED WITH McCABE, THE
FBI GENERAL COUNSEL, AND OTHERS
IN ADVANCE TO PLAN THEIR
STRATEGY TO SET UP THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT.
SO AFTER BRIEFING TRUMP ABOUT
THE DOSSIER AT TRUMP TOWER,
COMEY STARTED DRAFTING A MEMO TO
MEMORIAL EWES THE ENCOUNTER
DURING A CAR RIDE BACK TO THE
OFFICE.
THIS IS ALL PLANNED OUT.
THEN A DAY LATER ON JANUARY 11,
CNN REPORTED THIS.
>> THAT THE INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS
OF THE UNITED STATES WHEN THEY
BRIEFED PRESIDENT OBAMA THURSDAY
AND PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP ON
FRIDAY, THEY BELIEVED THAT THE
SOURCE OF THE DOSSIER WAS
CREDIBLE AND HIS SOURCES WERE
CREDIBLE AND THEY BELIEVED THAT,
A, THE PRESIDENT-ELECT AND THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD KNOW THAT THE
RUSSIANS WERE CLAIMING THEY HAD
COMPROMISED INFORMATION ON HIM.
>> THIS IS DISGRACEFUL.
THAT OPENED, OF COURSE, THE
MEDIA FLOOD GATES AND A WAVE OF
DAMAGING AND TOTALLY FRAUDULENT
DAMAGING AND TOTALLY FRAUDULENT FAKE NEWS STORIES FOLLOWED ABOUT
FAKE NEWS STORIES FOLLOWED ABOUTTHE PHONY CLINTON FINANCE FIELD
THE PHONY CLINTON FINANCE FIELD
DOSSIER.
NOW, IN THE MONTHS THAT
FOLLOWED, COMEY MEMORIAL
Y’ALLIZED HIS OTHER MEETINGS
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
SEVERAL MEMOS WERE SENT TO HIS
PERSONAL LAWYER, DANIEL
RICHMOND, WHO, THEN, AT COMEY’S
BEHEST, SHARED THE CONTENTS OF
AT LEAST TWO OF THEM WITH THE
NEWS MEDIA.
WHY?
TO SPARK THE APPOINTMENT OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL TO INVESTIGATE
POSSIBLE TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
BUT THE PRESIDENT SMELLED A RAT.
HE CONFRONTED AND ULTIMATELY
FIRED COMEY OVER THE LEAKS TO
THE MEDIA, WHICH, OF COURSE,
COMEY VOCIFEROUSLY DENIED.
>> I DON’T CONSIDER MR. RICHMOND
A LEAK, I TOLD HIM OF AN
UNCLASSIFIED CONVERSATION WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
>> ONE MONTH AFTER FIRING COMEY
AND NOW REACTION TO THE FORMER
FBI DIRECTOR’S CAPITOL HILL
TESTIMONY, TRUMP IN A TWEET
WROTE, DESPITE SO MANY FALSE
STATEMENTS AND LIES, TOTAL AND
COMEY IS A LEAKER.
COMPLETE VINDICATION, AND, WOW,
SO IS TRUMP RIGHT?
REGARDING THE LEAKING?
MAYBE COMEY NEVER CONSIDERED
RELEASING HIS OWN MEMOS LEAKING?
BECAUSE HIS ULTIMATE GOAL
BRINGING DOWN THE PRESIDENT, WAS
NOBLE.
HE SAW IT AS HE WAS CARRYING OUT
HIS CIVIC DUTY.
>> I INTENTIONALLY GAVE THIS
INFORMATION TO A FRIEND
INTENDING THAT IT BE OUT IN THE
MEDIA.
I WANTED IT TO GET OUT IN THE
AS A PRIVATE CITIZEN, I COULD DO
THAT AND DID THAT.
>> ACTUALLY, JIM, YOU WEREN’T
SUPPOSED TO DO THAT.
THIS IS PAGE 61 OF THE REPORT.
COMEY HAD SEVERAL LAWFUL OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO HIM TO ADVOCATE FOR
THE APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNSEL WHICH HE TOLD US WAS HIS
GOAL IN MAKING THE DISCLOSURE.
WHAT WAS NOT PERMITTED WAS THE
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE OF
SENSITIVE INFORMATION,
INVESTIGATIVE INFORMATION
OBTAINED IN THE COURSE OF FBI
EMPLOYMENT IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE A
PERSONALLY DESIRED OUTCOME.
SO, HE LEAKED.
AND LIED TO THE PUBLIC ABOUT IT.
THEN THERE’S THE QUESTION OF HOW
THEN THERE’S THE QUESTION OF HOWMANY MEMOS COMEY SHARED WITH HIS
MANY MEMOS COMEY SHARED WITH HIS
PAL, RICHMOND, FOR MEDIA
DISTRIBUTION AND WHETHER THEY
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
IN REPEATED INTERVIEWS, COMEY
SAID VERSIONS OF THIS --
>> I SENT MR. RICHMOND A COPY OF
A TWO-PAGE UNCLASSIFIED MEMO AND
ASKED HIM TO GET THE SUBSTANCE
OF IT OUT OUT TO THE MEDIA.
>> YOU PERSONALLY --
>> I GAVE HIM NOTHING ELSE,
EVER.
>> ONE MEMO, UNCLASSIFIED THEN,
STILL UNCLASSIFIED.
IT’S RECOUNTED IN MY BOOK.
>> Laura: THE BOOK.
BUT THE IG SAID IN PAGE 51 OF
THE REPORT, RICHMOND VOLUNTEERED
TO THE BUREAU AND HIS INTERVIEW
THAT IF YOU’RE COLLECTING THE
ONE, YOU SHOULD GET THE OTHER
THREE MEMOS RICHMOND HAD
RECEIVED FROM COMEY, WOOPS,
ADDING THERE COULD BE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION CONTAIN IN WHAT
RICHMOND RECEIVED FROM COMEY.
THAT’S THE KEY PART OF THIS --
THIS -- AS A REPORT.
COULD BE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
SO, REPEATED LEAKER, REPEATED
LIAR.
AND IN HIS INTERVIEW WITH BRETT
BARRY LAST YEAR, HE MADE THIS
LUDICROUS CLAIM --
>> THE FBI PROTOCOL SAYS YOUR
OWN EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT WITH
THE FBI PROHIBITS THE
UNAUTHORIZED DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION OR MATERIAL FROM OR
RELATED TO THE FBI FILES WHERE
ANY INFORMATION ACQUIRED BY
VIRTUE OF MY OFFICIAL EMPLOYMENT
WITHOUT WRITTEN PERMISSION FROM
THE FBI.
DID YOU HAVE PERMISSION?
>> NO, I DIDN’T CONSIDER IT AS
AN FBI FILE.
>> YOU WROTE IT AS AN FBI
DIRECTOR, IT WAS WORK PRODUCT.
>> IT WAS NOT.
>> YOU WERE TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> IT WAS MY PERSONAL MEME WITH
>> IT WAS MY PERSONAL MEME AY
>> IT WAS MY PERSONAL MEME ITH
A
>> Laura: FIRST OF ALL, ANY MAN
WHO SAYS AIDE DEMEMOIR IS
SOMEONE YOU SHOULD NOT TRUST.
COMEY’S CHARACTERIZATION OF THE
MEMOS AND PERSONAL RECORD FINDS
NO SUPPORT IN THE LAW AND IT’S
HOLY AND COMPATIBLE WITH THE
PLAIN LANGUAGE OF THE STATUTES,
REGULATIONS, AND POLICIES.
AND THE TERMS OF THE COMEY FBI
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT.
SO HE’S NOT JUST A LEAKER AND A
LIAR, HE’S INCOMPETENT OR,
PERHAPS, WILLFULLY IGNORANT.
NEITHER OF THOSE IS GOOD EITHER.
STILL, AFTER ALL THIS, COMEY HAD
STILL, AFTER ALL THIS, COMEY HADTHE GALL THIS MORNING TO TWEET,
THE GALL THIS MORNING TO TWEET,
DOJ-IG FOUND NO EVIDENCE THAT
COMEY OR THE ATTORNEYS RELEASED
NONE OF THE INFORMATION
CONTAINED TO ANY OF THE MEMOS TO
MEMBERS OF THE MEDIA.
I DON’T NEED A POLICY TO DEFAME
ME, BUT A QUICK MESSAGE OF,
SORRY, I LIED ABOUT YOU, WE’LL
BE NICE.
SORRY, JIMMY, DON’T HOLD YOUR
BREATH.
THE IG REPORT ESTABLISHED BEYOND
A SHADOW OF A DOUBT THAT COMEY
ENGAGED IN A BRAND PERSONAL
VENDETTA AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT.
AND IN DOING SO, HE ABUSED HIS
AUTHORITY.
AND WHILE COMEY MUST BE
BREATHING EASIER TONIGHT GIVEN
THE AG DECISION NOT TO PROSECUTE
HIM FOR THIS LEAKING, HE’S NOT
OUT OF THE WOODS YET.
THE IG REPORT ON THE FBI RUSSIAN
PROBE AND THE USE OF THE FISA
WARRANTS IS FORTHCOMING.
IT’S COMEY WHO SIGNED THE FIRST
FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
NOW, BASED ON THE DOSSIER,
NOW, BASED ON THE DOSSIER,HE KNE
HE KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN WAS
NOT CREDIBLE.
THAT WAS FILED WITH THE FISA
COURT.
BIG NO NO.
BUT, IF COMEY MANAGES TO ESCAPE
PROSECUTION FOR CONDUCT THAT HIS
UNDER LINGS WOULD BE CHARGED
FOR, THEN THE DAMAGE HE DID TO
THE FBI WILL EXTEND TO OUR
BELIEF AND THE TREASURED WORDS
CARVED INTO THE SUPREME COURT